thanks yes we are with Victor balogan
the executive director of Fida Victor
first of all welcome back to our show
you've been here in Romania last year as
well what are your first impressions of
the organizations here yes thanks thanks
for welcoming back and it's always a
pleasure and an honor to be at this
tournament it's one of the biggest and
most important tournament in the world
uh it's always good to be here I like
very much I think it's a bit different
setup this year it's more Spectators
which I always like when I played myself
on the stage when you have spectators
you play better and because you your
work is appreciated so that's what I see
for the first difference because I just
arrived this morning but otherwise
playing Hall is completely packed yeah
yeah but yeah okay it's Sunday today but
also it's it's a clear evidence that the
tournament is getting more and more
recognition and interest from the local
public it's also important not to have
only online which definitely the numbers
are growing up but also in physical
presence so that's what I like but in
general of course it's always on the
highest level possible the company the
organizers super bad they are doing very
good job and together with the Romanian
chest Federation so it's all pleasure
especially we had today already feed the
technical meeting today so it's more
more events coming in yeah that's great
and speaking of the biggest events that
you just mentioned we just had the
concluded world championship match
between uh Ding and Jan how did you
leave that from inside the organization
yeah I had the privilege to be in the
beginning of the match and definitely
again it was organized very well and
that I think this was the most combative
match out of if we compare with all
these draws in this Carlson karaoke in
carvana Carlson matches of course it was
more interesting maybe more mistakes but
it was very entertaining and uh okay
this was dramatic the final but
definitely even an absence of the form
world champion Magnus Carlson the match
was very interesting to watch and I'm
happy to see both participants here in
Bucharest of course it's very tiring for
them to play here after such they gave
everything they had all their energy
knowledge and but it's it's good to see
them here and I think that was a very
well organized match and it was a
success speak a bit about that what do
they have to do to get their energy back
because you've been a competitor at the
highest level as well how difficult it
is to come back with fresh ideas fresh
energy out there such uh it's smoking
it's not about ideas because usually if
you prepare for a world championship
match then the idea is prepared for a
Machi it can serve you for another year
unless we know this week of ideas from
doing side but okay that's another story
it's more about definitely energy
motivation and but all by old style by
all the fashion you would never play a
tournament in the next few months but
now we know that the calendar is very
tight which is much more popular they're
very important competition and of course
grantchester is not only one competition
it's a series of competitions and that's
why I think the players committed to to
play here I don't envy them you know
it's really a very big change and
practically it's by default that they
will be under their normal level to
participate here so but how to recover
of course you have to sleep you have to
get some fresh air so but this I don't
think it's the case for them because I
know for after a difficult game after a
difficult tournament the quality of
sleep is much worse so it's only
challenges I mean I I don't have a good
good recipe for them yeah well you guys
at fide are bringing a lot of
competitions here in Romania there's one
coming up in July the internet National
School stress Festival tell us a bit
about that I would say opposite actually
we have some feed has some good partners
and Romanian just federations in one of
them like kazakhstan's Federation for
example we had this the world
championship match there and we have the
world Blitz and Rapid there same in
Romania we have we organizes granchester
story organized many youth events and
the initiative about this tournament in
polished right impression by the way my
grandfather used to live all his life
and players
so so the initiative came of course from
the Romanian side and Jonas the
pronunciano he he will be he's already
the new the chairperson of this
organizations chess and school
organization so the initiative comes
from municipality from him from the
government and Via support we just
endorse it but it's very good moment for
this tournament to be organized because
the idea of the promoting of
inter-school competitions on the World
level on the global level uh it's
something new uh we had this tradition
and if you remember in Romania and
former Soviet Union and other countries
when we have the Center School
competitions now we bring it to the
level of global competition and after
immediately after that next month we
will organize also the world school
championship so this tournament this
Festival in place will be a very
important stage like repetition before
the championship and for me my first
game I won in my career it was in this
inter-school competition so I really
think it's very important competition
and we are thankful to the Romanian
organizers for this initiative it's
always a pleasure to hear that more and
more youth competitions and the new
generation is being nurtured here in
Romania Victor thank you very much for
joining the show and we'll see you
around thank you so much thank you thank
you
guys back